nine eight okay ponziani
arena tournament every game will be
ponziani
but not every game i'll be white oh i'm
playing fm okay
oh oops i didn't mean to pre-move that
okay so we're gonna um oh this is
actually one of the most
like sharp challenging lines um
black stacks a piece and then takes on
f2
it's interesting that we're starting
with this
um we'll see how prepared my opponent is
but bishop e6 is the main move and then
queen d5
yeah this gets really really sharp
and i think i'm supposed to take
on b7 i'm gonna lose a rook
after takes takes takes
oh castling opponent might be like
really prepared here
um yeah this is not your typical
ponziani like beginner friendly
just control the center it's just uh
position explodes before move 10.
so i'm considering rook g1 actually here
but also bishop e3 perhaps
the problem with bishop e3 is takes and
then rook b8 and b2 can fall
yeah i'm leaning towards rook g1 looks
kind of scary but
i do save the rook i'm temporarily up a
piece
my king is on e2 and most of my pieces
are not developed
so at least it'll be interesting
yeah this is kind of like a ponziani
mixed with a bomb cloud
okay now i cut off the bishop from
defending the knight
the queen is always having a square if
it gets attacked
yeah i'm not sure if e4 was uh was the
best move there
because this pawn um
i think it's gonna be fixed here for a
bit
unless black plays this
oh okay that's that's some idea
forgot that square was accessible
[Music]
oh my bishop's hit play king d1 maybe
there's also no queen e4 would be bad
okay so retreating the king
um but unleashing the bishop defending
this bishop
oh some people a lot of people already
won their first game good job people
yeah this is going to be a shorter arena
tournament than normal
i'm not sure if i'll be able to win it
but the the goal is to have instructive
games
and uh especially provide
some value to the the ponziani fans out
there
okay now if i take i get forked so
probably have to move this way
it's also queen d5
actually i kind of like queen d5
just more centralized that way if it
takes i can take back with queen
c6 is normal and queen f5 now
maybe queen here
a bit conflicted
or even queen here offering
a queen trade
problem is black can simplify a lot
b2 falls in the end
i think i'll play queen h5
that way the queen's a bit more out of
danger
um i still really just want to remove
the knight
black might go for the line takes takes
takes
and then maybe i play king c2
i'm probably objectively worse here my
opponent's opening preparation was good
but it can still get messy especially
with time ticking down
one player and clear first there's two
wins before
my first game is even finished
logical okay so now
it's very tempting just to take
and then probably focus on development
um it's also bishop no not bishop g5
okay let's take
wow that move i didn't see i've rook off
one
looks logical hitting the queen
so both bishops are hanging
oh i should have considered just taking
threatening mate but then there was g6
a very confusing position
okay now i have bishop here bishop e5
uh what is going on
i could also if i want to be really
brave
should i display my bravery
allowing a discovery
i feel so brave playing this move but my
my key pieces are on light squares
so bishop can't touch him that's a move
bishop four doesn't work i guess queen
of three
what's material that's scary okay this
move
so everything's defended take with
maybe king
oh so i have i have two miners for
rook and pawn
no i'm up two pieces i have both rooks
oh because black didn't take my rook
previously
i'm just completely winning yeah leech
us even tells me
oh maybe yeah maybe black went wrong at
some point
i wasn't really paying attention to
material
uh don't hurt me
i'll just play it safe and i mean
eventually i want to
win on the king side um
play this move first
it looks kind of scary but it takes i
have takes
the time is maybe the bigger issue here
but thankfully there's increments
i'm kind of botching this
okay nice move this simplifies so after
takes takes i
defend the rook
now i'll activate this rook
try and win the pawn
man i want a game to start the
tournament
and it don't get skewered there this
move and then this move
and this move probably oh there's a cool
mating idea
oh wait it takes
maybe there's not have this move
check
where's my mate i have to play this
man this game's taking taking very long
it's winning though yeah i give up the
bishop
and i'll save the knight
and then we'll go in for the the kill
oh no i messed this up
oh no
i messed this up no
what is this game i'm losing now
actually it's still interesting
kind of more interesting for black
though
trying made in one
this might be a draw actually
there's a funny perpetual queen here and
then we draw
what's going on here
oh that's a good move or is it no it's
not yes let's go i'm winning
let's go wow what a game
i i got the fork wow so that game
that game lasts a long time
not the best technique from either of us
um man
that was crazy that's already
more than one-fourth of the tournament
i'm currently
top okay i'm in the top
40. leader has won three games so far
man i have to go back and analyze that
game at some point
if you want to join we have the join
command
uh which should link you to the
tournament okay this time i'm black
oh it's my move let's play d5 this is
kind of
the principled move that um
yeah i think d5 d5 and knight f6 are
probably the two most common moves
but the point is after takes takes
there's no knight c3
so queen a4 is playable um
i kind of want to play a gambit here
i have a vague memory of svidler playing
knight f6 against hikaru
but i'll admit i haven't looked at this
in recent times
i think the idea is bishop d6
or is it take as it takes i think it's
bishop d6
i'm kind of improvising here
um
but yeah queen a4 is like the tricky
ponziani type move i've played it many
times before on stream
have some games on youtube um
like the the main line is f6
but uh yeah there's a few ways for black
to play in the gambit style
so opponents taking their time
and basically i'm gambling and gamuting
two pawns like if
white were to take d3
we might even be following this fiddler
nakamura game
i still have some vague memory of the
structure
um now i'm probably threatening to take
and
bishop choose a good move though
so perhaps rookie 8
okay now i can consider taking
oh i can take and
[Music]
oh it's tricky though
so i'm calculating takes takes takes
takes takes takes
and then takes takes check the problem
is if
after kg1 queen h4 there's um queen c8
but maybe that's still playable like
just rook b8
d4 respectable
about bishop g4 here
oh there's a there's a funny line takes
and then
oh maybe it doesn't work though i was
thinking i greek gift
but there's bishop f4 in the end
defending h2
so i guess i'll take this way and then
queen h4
trying to find my my threat here i might
just
rook lift or i might go for bishop h2
and trying one f2
but i'm kind of getting what i'm um
getting what i was hoping for from this
opening like speedy development
i'm not even down upon and uh yeah
light's a bit un
underdeveloped on the queen side
this move also something to consider
oh no my knight i forgot to say that
earlier
a knight is pinned to the mating square
oh oh no my pawn
so the move i really want to play is
this um
let's calculate this this takes takes
takes takes
if e3
i'll play rook b8 i just want to play
this and not blunder
my rook happy
four months eric hey happy four months
thank you rolosus and now
yeah now i'm threatening bishop h2
winning the queen
on top of that my rook swings in
and we're having lots more fun
um but am i meeting
oh there's a funny move knight h2 so
hitting the rook
unleashing my rook pinning the pawn
threatening queen h3
also threatening knight f3 perhaps
and there's just too much pressure here
sometimes easy to to miss this move
okay so now i guess i'll take and
enjoy life
this should be three all i'll start
lunging f pawn forward
yeah now the bishop's trapped
attack is raging on
that's fun game
i guess no matter which color i am i'll
try and play
oh let's not blunch her rook that's very
sneaky
uh can i save it
let's just play rook f8 bishop's still
trapped if knight e4 i take and
hit stuff
oh opponents being resourceful
queen takes would have pinned my pawn
love from sudan hey i love you too
welcome yeah i'm not sure how many
sudanese viewers i have
um could probably check on youtube
there's got to be at least a few
okay um how to do this
i just want to threaten mate the
knight's annoying let's get rid of it
i should make lou for my king
at some point because i want to do i
want to take on
e3 and then sack and mate
hard to defend e3
if i were white i would play queen d8
hoping to
um separate the queen
um okay let's play this
there might be some nice queen sack made
eventually
or some nice flag win okay okay
so two out of two but games are taking
longer than i would like
but okay still having some some
interesting fights
okay so we're gonna play the same line
it would be funny if my opponent played
what i just played
f6 okay main move
yeah this is one of the better lines for
black but you still kind of have to know
what you're doing because
the development is a little bit awkward
bishop e6 oh this is bringing back
memories
um one of my first times playing in an
over the board tournament i played
against gary
and he also played bishop e6
which i don't think is is a great move
it's playable
but the bishop sometimes ends up being a
target i'm wondering if i can play c4
and
d5 probably start with c4
just hitting the queen like more often
the bishop is better on d7 just to
neutralize
the pin
hola arthur hnn
yeah welcome everyone if you're just
joining the stream
i am running a a ponziani viewer
tournament
uh something a bit different than usual
okay so now i have two threats to take
the pawn and
to play d5 not easy to defend
black's gonna have to lose some material
here
oh the queen and rook attacked my bishop
very tricky so maybe knight c3
hitting the rook defending the bishop
hitting the pawn
not scared of rook g5 and i'd probably
take with this knight and
keep developing
okay so this knight really defends
everything
i'm up a piece
and a lot of great potential to attack
the black queen just given the opposite
side casting situation
kind of want to play this move
let's play this move hit the queen feel
like my next several moves will
be just direct attacks or initiative
now i develop the bishop of tempo
i might end up taking and going for
knight b5
i think still knight b5 so i'm
threatening the pawn
oh i could have taken the pawn directly
but this is maybe trickier because i'm
threatening to fork
and then this pawn is also a target
that's a move though play this move
turning mate
so yeah three attackers only one sad
defender
if rook c6 i fork
um
[Music]
play b4 want to play b5 the knights pin
to the
c7 pawn and yeah this opens the file
you can take this starting mate and
bishop block the queen from defending
and probably just have time for a few
more games after this one
um
just keep the pressure threatening to
take
man strong chest mood is so strong
22 points
okay there goes all box pieces okay
pleasant game had one of those like
mainline kind of sharp
opening positions um got the early
tactics
oh goodbye to stokkvis yeah thanks for
stopping by
you know it's probably work hours in
europe right now
so a lot of people still uh a lot of
people above me
yeah first place was played like the
most amount of games
okay
oh uh not too much
oh it's my move let's play f5 aggressive
move
it's it's so it's um it's easy to forget
black moves first
in the sort of thematic tournament
also got distracted from the kind
complement
play queen f6 so f5 it's kind of a
an offbeat gambit but still very
playable
i think i just win a pawn here
interesting develop with check
i should maybe should have considered
queen c5 there's queen d4
let's slide slide over
okay pleasant position
i want to play d5 soon
this is actually very pleasant
even though my king's still in the
center i'm gonna build up a
a very strong center
just with the pawns white still a bit
underdeveloped
very pleasant pawn chain i also gave
room for my bishop to
retreat if necessary
oh there will be more don't worry i
might uh yeah at some point
i'll probably do like a longer ponziani
viewer tournament
i made this one shorter just because
candidates are starting very soon
actually it starts in about 10 minutes
um let's develop
but you can still late join that's the
great thing about uh these arena
tournaments
even if you show up late you can still
play a few games
kind of like this move get the rook
involved
keeping the pawns together if queen a4
check i play
king f8 king is reasonably safe
we might see this move
i probably just want to keep advancing
i have two center pass pawns
this is my my fake castling effort
i might have very few squares to move to
and d3 will come
man this is so much fun just keep
pushing the center pawns
um don't want to get too carried away
or do i let's keep pushing
oh okay let's get the knight involved
jake with queen
i wanted to play this but then takes
with check
um hey it's smothermate let's go
okay that was a fun finish not every day
you get two pawns
so deep into the opponent's territory um
pretty early in the middle game too
okay playing black um
let's play knife six haven't played this
yet i thought you cared
i do i just uh
i sleep at not right now i sleep at
different times
let's take here i'm gonna play the same
line my um
my first opponent played against me this
bishop c5
variation the bishop e3
it's um probably just a little bit worse
for white
in this move
but thanks for the ten dollars eric's
sleep schedule
i slept from like 2 p.m
to 11 p.m
it's hard to have like consistency
but uh
i am getting enough sleep so i'm awake
right now
making the european and asian viewers
happy
let's um yeah let's go for this
so if g3 i take
because of the h file pin the battery
pin
if my h5 if the plug was still on h7 the
queen would defend the rook
effectively but yeah now everything is
kind of crumbling for white
so i'm up the exchange and
[Music]
a pawn
oh no da i miss that oh no i'm losing
too
c6 doesn't work or does it
i could try c6 just to maybe confuse my
opponent
ah i'm in trouble
don't hurt me
i'm worse here if white plays the right
move
hmm yeah white should have taken the
rook
and then threatened rook h8 but now i
take and
everything is a-okay
queenside castle here too defend the
pawn
i was a small scare
it's like kind of falling down a flight
of stairs
but landing on my feet
i feel like a cat but cats don't really
fall down stairs
they more just like fall out of windows
and then
come out unscathed okay let's go for the
mating idea
um got two more moves away from meat
not forcing by any means but oh actually
i am
threatening i was running made in two
with rookie two
ah i'm getting for it
okay not the highest quality game
oh thanks for the bits nasaki and joshua
this is a good thing about being up so
much material
you can blend your stuff and still be up
a sufficient amount
okay so now the plan is this this and
meat
okay running made in two here
there we go okay i think we'll have time
for one more game
yeah not going to finish in first good
job to strong chess mood
winning games quickly
but it's fun um like i actually like the
concept of doing
a thematic viewer tournament i was
inspired by the hikaru staffer
tournament
so i think i might do more of these
because it makes for
more kind of specific youtube content as
well
um okay let's play queen a4
and for future ones i'll i'll try and
promote them while i have time
this was a bit more spontaneous
um okay so this line i can take the
bishop and then take on e4
and be up a pawn
apply some pressure
and keep queens on the board i could
have traded a lot of stuff
but focus on development
so one of the drawbacks with ponziani is
like queen side development's a little
bit slower than usual
but as long as you can get d4 in
um here it looks like i can take queen
takes i
would win that
play this move
interesting
knight c4 there's also this move
what to do i'll play this move
looks a little bit risky
i still have this move
i'll play this first hitting the bishop
improving the knight
get the king safe
still debating whether to throw in the
check
i think now it makes sense because i'll
take with night threatening this
which is not easy to stop because i'm
also preventing
oh that's a move
well played for my opponent
oh no the back rank
everyone's considering it
that queen here would be a blunder
because uh i would take and then rook f1
now i oh it's not meeting though
queenie for a good defensive move
i was trying to debate my opponent there
let's play h3
it's kind of backfiring now
oh i'm down a pawn but i do have a
slightly safer king
oh it's getting a bit messy
it's hard to exploit the black king
this move check
man how to do this
my argument will be that the pawn count
isn't as important as king safety
so lock could potentially be up two
pawns
actually both of our kings are are a bit
unsafe
so this this could be a crazy finish to
the tournament
i might be threatening queen a5
now it's less powerful
probably still queen a5 though
a simple way to attack the pawn
i mean i wanted to play rook a3 but then
i get mated
it's really hard to judge this position
um
and black does have to defend there's
rook b7 and rookie seven
or some queen move
queen moves i could trade and win f7
is actually kind of interesting
just going to a rook ending
this seems wrong because i'm still down
a pawn
but the thing is it's hard for black to
defend the c pawn
and my rooks activate really quickly
um that's also important i can take and
defend
which i think i want to do
[Music]
there is another idea though there's
actually a crazy idea in this position
to allow
takes here
now i want to take and defend
so i don't give the black black option
of taking
hmm that's still really tricky though
okay there's kind of a crazy line which
i'm trying to
to figure out
determine has officially ended okay here
i
start with checking
and then this move this should be
winning for white
threatening made in one or made in two i
guess
so black's gonna have to resort to being
passive
and then it's a typical end game
situation when you control the seventh
rank
with the rooks but you're not quite
meeting
um let's take
this way threatening made in one
i'll put the rock the rook back on g7 to
defend
and now i win the pawn and everything's
safe now
king's cut off the spawn's defended life
is good
thank you shane no nellis gifting
a sub
okay so we'll threaten this move again
yeah sometimes the best way to win a
position like this is just patience
and slowly but surely i'll march the
pawns forward
i just want to play h5
the king will kind of find shelter
between the rooks and pawns
i'm basically guarding the king along
the the ranks or the the rank and the
file
or the file in the rank um
so we see the same pattern of it's kind
of like a caterpillar
like the way a caterpillar moves like
you you inch up
like you expand and then contract
okay that was pleasant a caterpillar
endgame technique
um there was an interesting moment which
i was trying to figure out
when i took on c7 black has a move rook
g2
engine is just saying draw um
which i would probably trust but it gets
kind of weird because
um first of all if i take
then we just trade brooks and this
should be a drawn ending
but i was calculating uh check here
check here and then this with idea that
after here
here and whichever rook checks i move to
f1
and then there's no more check on f2 and
i thought i might have
chances here to win but
engine still just says it's a draw
because there's no great way like this
just trades
oh nice to hear yeah thanks to everyone
who played the tournament
it is it is uh officially over
uh we'll get some more confetti if you
ever start your own newspaper
you should call it the rows and columns
oh wait is that a pun or is that just a
genuine suggestion
the rosin columns
well thanks for the suggestion zan man
uh and yeah thanks to the 382 people who
competed
good job to strong chess mood and
bulti bultsy 1796 an intuition pump
um oh i finished outside of top
top 10. um
yeah i had some fun games i'll probably
put the whole thing on youtube
um nice to have kind of a series of
of ponziani games from from both
perspectives too from white and black